erika takes us on a ghost hunt did your
hair tag on you know blown on breeze on
i'm hopefully it's not the neighbor next
to you any questions before we head down
the first stop is a hallway erica
believes is haunted by the ghost of a
young mechanic male by the name of john
likes to play with us down here from
time to time he's 18 and he passed away
July 10th 1966 during a routine fire
drill right here in watertight door 13
according to the story John was working
here in the engine room when the fire
drill began realizing he left his wrench
behind he quickly jumped back through
the closing hydraulic door but he timed
his job badly and was crushed to death
like other unlucky souls who died on the
Queen Mary some believe John is doomed
to stay with the ship this ghost has
reportedly been seen and heard by
numerous witnesses will John make an
appearance tonight now I'm just gonna
kind of you know go with me I may seem a
little bit crazy but I'm just gonna kind
of call out to him and see if he'll talk
with us anyway we're counting on you
this is this is this room is usually
he's he's usually the most interactive
out of all of the people that we're
dealing with all right John we need you
to talk with us
now if you're wanting to take pictures
perhaps John is feeling shy in that
direction and over here but Ericka has
other means of communicating with ghosts
dowsing rods make a fist around the
outside like that so you're kind of
holding them perfect and what is your
name okay Gabe very nice to meet you
Gabe and if you want to just close your
eyes for a minute okay
and then go ahead and take a few deep
breaths and release any stresses of the
day all right you ready okay John we
have Gabe here holding the dowsing rods
is there any way that you could you
could let us know that you're here by
crossing those dowsing rods for us
somebody saw something going up my leg
okay dowsing your eyes are amazing thank
you John we truly appreciate you being
here with us